this is the grounded podcast episode two
with Dean Lister and me Jocko Willick
d-list chuckle okay couple questions to
talk about today and this is something I
think will help people not just
necessarily in the kind confines of the
subject matter that we normally talk
about which is the jujitsu slash fight
world but also just in everything so
people are going into a stressful
environment ie a competition a fight a
match something like that and different
people well like okay so people get
nervous
people get the butterflies yeah and how
do you handle that and I know you have
coached and trained all kinds of you
know the best in the world
world champions what have you seen from
your experience on how to handle those
things nerves that the what is that the
proper work nerves knows how to handle
nerves how to handle adrenalin how to
handle expectation right expectation of
what's about to happen or no no I think
the word is anticipation right the
anticipation is worse than than the
actual event yeah yeah so what have you
seen what can you talk about how can you
help us well that's that's one of the
most common questions I get asked for
sure absolutely
first of all everyone is definitely
different so it's not like one thing
it's gonna be the secret for everyone I
was coaching I was friends with a Mirko
Cro Cop Viva [ __ ] and Croatia before
fights he actually will just play poker
with also Croatian friends and just
he'll be laughing until it's time to put
the clothes on and warm up and if I'm
not mistaken he's also after if I went
back and played poker not longer he just
he's just not that says how he would he
would access so I've caught this I've
caught myself doing this to everyone
does this before a competition you start
replaying in your mind everything that's
gonna happen what if the guy does
this all of this and then I'll do a
backflip and then okay cuz like you know
you just think of these crazy things and
your heart starts racing or you start to
get so you mean that in a negative way
yeah you're ghetto instead of
visualizing like because you know some
people say I visualized the entire fight
I walked in I did the walk out I walked
down the ramp I got into the cage the
fight went exactly I'd already won in my
mind a thousand times this is different
what you're talking about this isn't a
visualization of positivity
it's visualization of bad things have
this is not you can either way it's an
uncontrolled form of meditation it's not
even meditation is paid dreaming and
it's almost that feeling or you're in a
car you're almost get in an accident and
you just strong yeah you feel tired
afterwards well adrenaline just went
coursing through your veins and now it
just got depleted and now you're tired
so if if this is not controlled if this
is just reckless meandering thoughts
yeah it's not good for your energy and
this happens to almost everyone that's
why some days you're focused some days
you're not Mike Tyson had a great it's
on YouTube he talks about you know
mental games before fight and talks
about you know uh before his fight he's
not nervous he says it's wrong it's
wrong he said he's he's afraid of this
man is what's gonna hurt him this whole
this whole time training I mean being
not nervous not nervous is wrong is that
what you just said he's are you he's
saying you should be nervous
everyone's gonna show their amount of
nervousness different everyone's gonna
be a little there are more than less
nervous people this true
what I mean is he admitted it's it's he
those words were wrong he was nervous
before fights but the closer he got to
the ring the less nervous he was as soon
as he got in the ring he was a god and
no one could touch him because this man
wants to hurt me I'm gonna hurt him
first and I'm paraphrasing of course but
he put it in very good words up as far
as you know he's dreamed of this guy
beating him before he dreamed of it he
doesn't want that to happen and he's
putting the gloves on he's he's piercing
through the leather with his knuckles
and he's walking in the
rina but the closer he gets the more and
more confident he gets that's that's a
form of controlled visualization
meditation let's say that's controlled
though he's not meandering just getting
excited for no reason
also the more you compete the better you
will to relax so there's different ways
everyone relaxes some people don't even
relax at all when I was young I remember
Jacques who used to slap me in the face
three or four times before my fights and
now recently I'm like a jock I don't
need a kiss not anymore
I'm a little older now so it's the
younger people want to amp their energy
up the older people want to calm this
house down everyone's just a little bit
different there's no such thing as
someone who is exactly the same as
someone else I noticed that's one thing
I like about wrestling is when I see the
kids wrestle my own kids like you're
gonna go and wrestle they have a limit I
don't know if it's to live in anyone
else but in California and I know folks
like this when you were a kid but you
can only wrestle five times in a day so
if you wrestled five times you're done
for that day but that means you know on
a two-day tournament you'll get ten
matches in two days and that's that's
awesome it's the same with jiu-jitsu you
know if you go out you compete you're
gonna compete a lot you know you can
compete a lot you can do five matches in
one day you can do eight matches in one
day what's the most matches you've ever
had in one day for for grappling because
bro you used to go up do your weight
class 1 whatever 175 and then you'd
compete and absolute you'd have like 10
matches yeah in a day probably 10 is
probably about the maximum now part of
them I can't give you credit for cuz you
just submit people like fast you know do
you never look nervous going into a
grappling match that I've seen I don't
know I don't know you look nervous going
into a fight yeah you were so much more
comfortable
grappling than you were going into MMA
fights yeah I mean and part of it's
because the obvious you'd grappled
thousands and thousands of matches I
mean even before I even met you you'd
have done high school wrestling career
you done [ __ ] career
and now we were into you know our
jiu-jitsu career you're interested to
career so you already had time you would
never you look like when you talk about
cro cop playing poker like that's what
you were like you wouldn't be walking on
getting hyped for anything like that you
just walk out on the mat like a damn
this is like a damn zombie slash robot
that was about to start murdering people
with no feelings i'm did that actually i
think this one of your bet your favorite
stories involving myself but there was
the guy his last name was silver silver
but that's like saying smith yeah yeah
yes such a common last name you but as
many good fighters with last name
syllable apparently and it was in the
finals
i'd beat three guys eb three guys I mean
he submitted he was good
yeah and he was a very hyper she slapped
a mat look at you stare you down the
eyes and very emotional flat very most
grappler then I was just calm yeah I
remember that you know when someone is
that hyper and they're emotional and
they feed off the reaction in your face
that's why Fedor I think who stared on
it's really good because if you look at
him and stare him down it doesn't work
and when you see on his face that he
doesn't really care what you're doing
yeah that kind of like makes you feel
insecure or something yeah I don't know
so well that was like when Holly Holm
fought against raw Rodney Ronda yeah
remember Ronda was all agree and all
hype and everything she was going all
crazy
during the stair downs during the
weigh-ins and Holly was looking at her
like whatever and same with Joanna
versus thug rows and their first matchup
and Joanna's getting all crazy and thug
Rajas looking at her just no emotion
whatsoever and then outs but see I don't
think so I think it would have been
different results if on either or both
of those occasions the the calm person
was not calm back then you would have
played into the the original game yeah
because that that feedback would have
been received in that we're playing that
emotional game now if you don't it so
there we go that's a different way to
play the mental game and this this
situation so everyone's a little
different some fighters have that for
instance before it may it may fight as
one guys
hey do you really like looking at dudes
in the eyes do you really want to do
that no ok fine because that's not their
personality just look where it's right
through your chest
don't play the eye game because if you
play it and look away you lost the game
here but if you want to play that game
don't look away now you know you play
the game to play the game or don't put
the game so everyone is this different
there's no such thing as one guy exactly
the same as maybe similar but the terms
of relaxing or taking the pressure off
everyone's a little bit different
there's no such thing as the same my
opinion so so you got cro cop on the one
end of the spectrum and he's like a guy
that's cold as ice and part of the
reason is cuz he'd fought so many times
you know i talked about you being in
grappling matches at being totally
mellow cro cop had so many fights as a
striker that you think he for him
walking into the cage he's not really
nervous about anything because he's been
punched plenty of times and it's not
that big of a deal
under the skill we have we have one
fighter which we know you know him
professional fighter now and has fought
the UFC great friend of ours his first
fight he actually said he started crying
and said I don't wanna be here and I
said calm down calm down he goes no I
that guy's too tough and he was crying
he's this is this is a big man that
crying was his I never seen him cry and
this is like an awkward moment cuz he's
was supposed to go out and fight and
everyone sit around waiting for him he
said I want to leave but I said no
you're not gonna leave basically I had I
had to kind of say no you're not doing
that
you're gonna fight so he said ok oh my
god I don't know I'm doing and went out
there and finished the guy in the first
round so he actually need a little
outside help to relax but he actually
won so the thing is that guy couldn't
have played poker than that day at that
moment he would have lost every hand ok
so maybe is that experience probably it
is it's definitely something of all in
personality as well though because Crow
cops a little bit he's got those serial
killer eyes a little bit I don't know
it's got that little bit of detachment I
know him personally he's a good friend
of mine but he has that detachment in
his
this whole crew like I remember watching
them play poker like everyone was pacing
and everyone's doing all whatever their
pre-fight nerves are going and he's
sitting with all them big gnarly looking
dudes and they're just sitting around
the other guys are like smoking and
drinking yeah whatever
and he's playing poker with him he's
ready to go to battle yeah like like
that he can be taxed himself yeah and so
I mean that's a good way to award to use
an emotional versus detachment maybe
that they can they could fall in lying
there somewhere as far as in comparison
but some fighters are very emotional
some fighters find it easier to detach
but it's always gonna be as long as we
are a human being and we think outside
of this room like what can happen and
people ask me like how do you know
you're gonna win I say well actually I
never know I was gonna win that sounds
weird am i insecure no no no no it's not
like I'm doubting myself I just don't I
can't read the future I can't read the
future and one time is before I think it
was before a fight you're gonna rot who
was from Bulgaria very good fighter a
fighter than UFC and you said something
like you're in the locker room with me
hey Dean what's wrong you know look very
you don't look very relaxed I'm
paraphrasing you said and I went well
you know my pony he's a real good
kickboxer he's a really good wrestler
and and I'm I was thinking he's going
something like he hit me with a knee in
the head when I grabbed him and he went
yeah you know well in Iraq and I was
like god damn it the guys are late
already and your whole story was you
know we're going on a mission we know
what we're going but we don't know
what's gonna happen but we're going to
this this building to take it down or
whatever we know who we're looking for
we know the route we're going what we're
pretty sure it's it's the right way to
go but sometimes you get blown up you
get blown up sometimes like I felt like
kind of like a pansy at the moment
because I'm just gonna to fight the guy
I'm not gonna get killed but they put
things in perspective because your point
was you're going out to do the job
anyways doesn't matter if you get hit
with a knee it doesn't matter you're
doing it anyways so why do I doubt that
I already know what I'm gonna do so as
far as knowing no one can predict the
future I guess has another way of saying
what you said to me that fight day
you can't predict the future but we know
we're here to fight we know we're here
to walk out when we know our true self
put ourselves in this situation to
better ourselves and to get more
experience so take some comfort in that
that thought in this cotton and just
live the match live your mom that's a
good point if you if your attitude is
hey I'm here to learn and I'm gonna try
and win of course but if I don't win
then cool I'm gonna learn something
about myself and that's fine that's part
of the reality of it
well you do you get nervous before
grappling matches nervous yeah it's it's
more excitement it's you know wouldn't
my one of my fights my mom and my sister
were there just like the only time that
ever happened uh-huh that was a fight
that was in king of the cage it was
against oh my goodness I forget what was
anyways yeah I wanted to fight without
getting punched so it was it was a good
fight for me to have a VIP invited my
sister my mom but I was just I couldn't
get over the fact that they're there now
my dad watched me get hit it's not so
bad so that was a just example of
something I didn't want to replicate for
the next fight so it depends on certain
things um if I find no I've trained hard
I feel less nervous I don't see nerves
is like the right word just say I feel
alive I feel in the moment talking about
what what what wills gears the
difference between a grappling and a
fight like I get for a fight because
I've seen you buearu nervous for fight
and you know why am i nervous for fight
because there's a higher percentage of
chance right there's a chance I mean in
my opinion there's a in in a fight in an
MMA fight there's a more chance plays
into it there's many more uncontrolled
factors more on control factor I mean
you could get you could get caught with
a punch and boom you're done right that
that could happen there's a whatever
percentage you want to call that there's
a 12% chance of that happening a 7%
whatever percent you want to call it
that is zero percent in a integrand
perhaps it's 0% that you're gonna get
caught with a punch and
now that's not gonna happen in trapper -
yeah you you're not gonna get caught
with an e you're not gonna get you're
not gonna get caught with a headbutt and
get well I guess you could call with a
headbutt and get cut
so anyways there's just a higher
percentage of chance there's also
there's also some fine finality to
getting knocked out right yeah if you
get caught in a submission like you have
there's it's not fun it's not over until
you tap out and for you that must be
pretty good because you are very good at
escaping submission will call them
submission attempts I mean you have been
you have had
Jean J Ribeiro arguably one of the
greatest you know world champions ever
he had you in a freakin arm lock and you
got out of it I mean you've been in
you've been in Yuma padas you've been in
heel hooks you've been in chokes you've
been in you've been in in paid upon oh
who at the time was just undefeated
beast no one was even frickin scoring on
him just a giant you were in his arm
triangle for four five five minutes
right and so so it's like you have a
power to get out so I'm just saying
maybe that's why your nerves for
grappling or so calm because you didn't
even feel a threat I don't know I
actually I don't know why I do this or
maybe why I had the ability to do this
but when I feel like I'm supposed to be
hurt or damaged or I am injured or
something I feel like I get it
simplifies things in my mind for some
reason so it also a great fighter in
kakaako had me an arm guillotine for he
had the best guilt in the world just
ranked it was the best guilty in the
world and he had moved for 30 seconds
there and I was in it and I could hear
the crowd scream and they got silent cuz
he's choking me in that bit my ear I
can't even hear my ear it sort of
muffling that he's choking me but I
thought about it like wait choking you
mean you were starting to lose
consciousness or just the squeeze of the
armors process arm was barking ahhh
sound because you had an elbow in would
you have it the
well I blocked his hip in my elbow
that's why I didn't get her my armpit
that helped me a lot but it still I
think most would adopt it still sucks
yeah and I remember being in it thinking
oh I remember before the match seeing
saying myself oh you know 18 be careful
about his leg locks 18 be careful was
guilty I was like yeah he said be
careful about his leg locks no people
told me that they said yes the best late
marks in Brazil who knows if he did but
he he's ranked as a most feared guilty
in the world at that time and so I was
thinking yeah be careful and then I
thought wait a second I'd be careful of
it like why not just why not escape it
you know I'm not saying well I didn't
let him put it on me but as soon as I
see that he was going for this I was
like what kind of like we're committed
it's gonna happen I want to see if I can
escape this and that's a different a
different way of I'm not nervous now I'm
excited to want to escape you played a
little mind game on yourself
yeah consciously or unconsciously did
you play that mind game on yourself
looking back on it it's clear that that
relaxed you yeah I did remember number
one um I faced the Jamaal Patterson from
New York and my knee was hurt really odd
and people don't know your knee because
I it was a hematoma you saw nothing bad
when swelled up like it was bad I put
two knee pads on it
and I was thinking like okay don't don't
put your knee on the ground
I was like you know just forget about it
it just just take him to it made it so
simple I I don't know why I made things
so simple
I'm not saying was easier made things so
simple in mind and then he went for my
knee that he attacked her and and I was
it was kind of like it woke me up it
woke me up like like you know come on
you could escape this and then of that
woke me up for some reason I don't know
why it doesn't make sense to me
completely so it's probably subconscious
you know hmm
and then what about overtime so when you
were when when we were 19 you 19 we
first started training and then compared
to you know when you were 30 20 years
later when you're 39 or for the 17 years
later did your did your nerves calm down
over time were they worse were they
worse at a time when I don't remember
when I wasn't with you at your first
ADCC in Brazil
you nervous for any of those matches hmm
will you nervous for the fruit because
you lost yeah the first day in your
weight class you lost were you nervous
for those matches than you think you
weren't nervous anymore when you went to
the absolute I think I put it in good
words right now on my head I've done
better when I didn't have the pressure
yeah they didn't much lose so so I'm
just now people knew who I was it wasn't
I was an unknown but I was not supposed
to even be in the absolute division so I
can't screw it I I was think to myself
why not just go out there and just just
be a nuisance to my opponents just be a
news to me a pain in the ass my blister
come on man like God you know just be a
pain in the ass to everyone and then
have fun doing it and and actually
motivate myself and so every time I was
in trouble I was like what if I escaped
this is that that simple it wasn't I
need to win or I'm in trouble it's like
wouldn't it be cool that's that's what
was wouldn't it be cool if I scared this
wouldn't that be pretty cool that's
where I said it myself
because I was new jokes and I thought to
myself wouldn't it be cool and yes it
was cool when I escaped them so you know
and then when at the finals Kakariko I
mean that move no one was doing 50-50 no
and I did it and you can see on my
opponents eyes he doesn't know what's
going on and I got him in so imagine I
did not I'm not the first person in
history to use that position there's no
way of the thousands of years people has
done it before
I've even seen a picture of an omoplata
that's like 2,000 years old
I've seen it standing in water so these
are these are old things of course
someone has done it but no one taught
that to me and it worked and I want out
of a w so when I got relaxed or I could
try things out and actually have fun it
was incredible
is that like when you want a like a
basketball game and I think it's
basketballs a good example because the
scoring is so rapid but if someone gets
goes up by four five six seven points
all of a sudden they take a little bit
more risk they're a little bit more
confident they have less pressure and
then they go all of a sudden they go
from being up four points to be enough
not like 19 points in a very short
period of time because the or
soccer's another good one even though
it's the opposite end of the spectrum
once a team gets you know two to zero
they're gonna win and so now they can
like take more chances and they put even
more pressure on the goal so that's
similar to what you're saying on
yourself you put less pressure on
yourself or there actually is less
pressure like in your first in 2003 you
already you lost your weight division
okay so okay you're out you're your
loser
whatever yeah yeah and then all of a
sudden okay you're gonna go in there hey
it doesn't really matter you've you've
already competed your weight division
just gonna go out have fun do your best
and then when you do that when you kind
of I don't want to say this to create
when you throw caution to the wind and
you start taking chances and you start
letting your game just go that is a very
positive thing you know and then it was
a they actually interviewed Josh Burnett
after I lost to him I said um is it true
that the list resin in submit in 17
years and he said yeah it's true last
time Lister was submitted was during the
Clinton administration that was kind of
funny he said like that but here's what
happened there's other factors as well
of course as well as apart at being an
incredible athlete but I remember now
looking back that day the day before the
day before he you know you haven't Miss
Smith in 17 years that was the main
thing the hell was online I had
something to lose subconsciously so I
was cautious to keep that it's so common
I realized yeah you know I can be
instead of going hey screw it I'm gonna
in in and you know what you said about
the team in basketball that gets up and
awesome but also check it out you get
the team that gets up by 20 points in
football and the coach goes hey don't
blow it or by 20 points don't screw up
and the other teams like hey let's win
40 to 20 now right so it depends on if
the that's the opposite mentality the
people that are down by 20 they start
taking huge chances they got nothing to
lose they might as well go for it and
boom they're the ones that exactly yeah
that the Barnett thing and like you said
he's an unbelievable competitor but I
don't think you should have done that
competent
and I'm the one that trains with you but
you had injuries going into it like
that's the worst bro I was beating you
up going into that competition and I
should've not let you I mean we we were
only couldn't train very often because
you were injured when we were training I
was beating up which I cannot normally
do and I should have just been like hey
don't do this because you're not ready
you know that's one of those things I I
should have never looking back on it
that's just not it's not a good way to
go you know yeah but but you know it has
happened where I'm not doing well and
then all the good competition no there's
a difference I think there's a
difference between what we're talking
about um you're talking about you've
trained and then you get sick at the
last minute or the day of you have an
injury the day of but you're trained and
you're prepared and you can overcome
that you were in a situation on that one
where you were you weren't able to train
to prepare for it you know what I mean
yeah and so look man I've trained you
for so many different things and
sometimes I might have a good time
beating you up a little bit at the at
the 12-week mark without you do you know
of this 12-week mark of a training camp
where you're just starting out by the
end of it in the good when you're ready
I can't what I need is to bring three
more other guys three other guys in with
me I need to bring three other guys in
with me so that I can call because I can
do a tag team after four minutes when
you're like abusing me like I'm a
freaking child and I can tag someone out
and they can come in fresh and get you
that's the way it's supposed to be and
that camp it wasn't like that
and as a matter of fact now that I think
about this whole story it was a 20
minute match yeah and I had done a
couple days where I put fresh guys on
you
like I did like a tag team thing and you
just got beat down because you you just
you know you were injured you were sick
you were hurt and you hadn't been
training and so you got a beatdown and
then three days later it was like a
Saturday and you said let's just go you
and me 20 minutes and I
in my mind I was like damn it he's gonna
beat me up and then you didn't beat me
up and I realized I was like this has
never happened that actually had never
happened before and so that's when I
knew you know what that's what I should
have said Dean this is not the right
time you you should wait you should
recover you should train hard for six
months and do a match then so I take
that one as definitely my fault
and and and I also blame Josh Barnett
for being awesome hey you know what's
cool too man this stuff that Josh did
symbolically to tie back to his roots to
to the to the Japanese wrestling and I
thought that was cool too so props to
Josh but uh you know what in there Matt
okay I'm trying to put this in good
words in my life when I've done well
I've won and lost because what primarily
usually at one but off of different
reasons
I've won matches but being tougher won
matches on being innovative one matches
off of being strong and whatever I think
these are all different qualities you
need to have at the higher level but the
idea of making your opponent endure your
your energy versus you and during the
opponent's image or force that that's
that's when I've done really well is
when so this match I accepted
Barnett's weight and his his aggressive
movement and I just endured it I wasn't
I wasn't responsive to it in time and
what I've done well is when I'm making
my opponent react to me oh yeah so
that's it's the willingness to engage
the enemy
yeah and I'm saying yeah no I mean and
of course you know if anyone thinks I'm
sitting here saying Josh isn't like an
unbelievably unbelievabl beast of an
athlete and like I love the fact that
he's you know a submission based you
know catch wrestling guy he's just
awesome so but from seeing the whole
thing from my perspective it was a
bummer than and I should have as a
training partner as a coach I should
have said hey man don't do this and one
thing that's very hard for me to do with
you is get you to pull out of a match
you know cuz I would say I was thinking
that maybe three weeks out I started
saying you know what we're not gonna get
there and I should have said hey man
dude just stop like let's reschedule
this thing and there's I think in my
mind I thought there's no way you're
gonna pull out of a match three weeks oh
well you're not gonna be disrespectful
to a legendary guy like Josh Barnett and
not you know do the competition so maybe
that was a little bit of a of a lost
cause well talking about being nervous
before a match there are certain times
when it's not the time for you compete
but that's that's the rare situation
what is more common is someone making an
excuse not to compete because of this or
this or this and interesting enough is
to think like okay I need to I need to
get in shape to compete okay that makes
sense but but if that's always your
excuse
I mean at some point he's got to compete
to get it to get it going you know I've
heard people say I need I need to I need
to get in shape to learn Jitsu yeah
that's almost like someone's saying I
need to learn French before I go to
French class I mean just you gotta go in
and learn the movements and you get you
get in shape by doing the sport there so
competing is similar I mean there's
always an excuse I mean it happens all
the time there's always a reason not to
compete but the more you don't compete
the more you find these these mind games
that mess up your your rhythm the longer
you have work your your style is is not
benefited from your competition yeah
yeah so that was good you know the other
thing you were saying about Mike Tyson
and I think this is an important part to
think about and I last last podcast I
was talking about how much humility you
have in the fact that your mind is open
and I believe that the reason that your
mind is open is because you're a humble
person and you look at other people and
you think all that maybe that person
could do that better than me and when
you said about Mike Tyson Mike Tyson
would think that the person he was gonna
fight was gonna kill him
and therefore that what's that gonna do
it's gonna make you train freaking hard
so that's another good reason to to stay
humble because as you as you train and
there's you know I there's a there's a
little dichotomy which is
if you okay you you have to have a coach
right that's gonna push you but the
coach can only push you to 96% the only
person that can push you to 1% is you
yeah like you can always hold back a
little bit hey I can make you do more
freaking jump squats but that's not the
same as you going a hundred percent on
the jump squats you can add more
repetitions but it's not the same so
that's another part I think that is
important when it comes to humility is
you know you respect your opponent and
and that's one thing I can say about
like Josh Barnett
you knew that here's a guy that's strong
he's a grappler he's a wrestler you knew
that that was gonna be game on and you
know like I said you were training hard
but we couldn't train like we normally
would and that's my fault no you know
you know it's it's like it's something I
figured out it took me a long time to
figure this out like how hard you train
versus training to get in the zone and
if you're not getting in the zone
it doesn't matter already train because
nothing's working out for you so if
you're not if you just trooper if you
train hard hard hard hard it's better
than it's better than no training it's
absolutely better than no training but
if you can figure out a way to get in
your zone and make things work for
yourself that would be better for you
know so getting in the zone is I think
that's a good thing to aim for do you
think that do you don't you think though
when you train that opens up the zone
for you it opens up you the opportunity
to get in the zone yeah there we go I
find that the more I train the bigger
opportunity I have of getting into the
zone but if you do and I think you'll
agree with this for sure if you train
too much you start to close the
opportunity to get in the zone yeah you
can you can definitely over train and
you can get to a point where it's not
being beneficial to you and I definitely
have done that to you over the years
especially in the early years you know
we I train you so hard I could see you
start to go down and then we'd you know
we'd take time off or give you a few
days off you know so you could like a
recover
Jacque whatcha say hey Dean I think you
need a day off if jock who says that's
you yes there's a real reason you do
need a off if I tell you need a day off
you definitely need you know we're not
doing a second workout today just you
know oh really yeah
yeah no trust me just go and watch movie
out have a good day yeah eat some steak
dude get some steaks
what do you think the different types of
things that cause the anxiety to be
present that's it that's a there we go
see now we're looking at okay what is
what's the reason what's the root cause
the root cause well it's it what's
different there's a lot of overlap here
I mean are you afraid of damage can you
hurt that's normal
are you free to be humiliated are you
afraid of maybe realizing you're not as
strong as you thought you were are you
nervous that but I'm saying that it's
realistic I'm not I'm not talking for
sure really for sure
is that a fear instead of the fear of
weakness is it are you embarrassed
you'll look silly in front of other
people are you worried about an opponent
dominating you
and feeling helpless are you worried
you're gonna be tired and out of shape
and feel and feel like you're you have
not been training hard are you worried
the truth will be exposed well that's I
think that's the one of the group cause
with the truth the truth is ugly the
truth is ugly the truth is ugly the
truth the truth is ugly especially if
you are presenting a different facade
that doesn't represent the actual truth
so if you're walking around acting like
a tough guy and you're afraid that you
in deep and deep in your heart you think
that maybe you're not as tough as you
think you are you're afraid that that
truth is going to be exposed that's
definitely gonna be a problem yes yes
that's a problem it's a problem that can
be a problem so what is it what is it
usually it's being humiliated in front
of people and feeling weak and dominated
this that's int okay the physical aspect
that's that's of course that's there but
it's usually the idea of being
embarrassed and feeling weak that's
usually that's a universal feel fear I
think you know a matter of fact
the absolute horror of being so fatigued
you can't move but that's a terrible
feeling and I know I know how it is you
can um oh no you can always push it yeah
you can always think you can but there's
a moment where you know I can do 11
squats I can't do 12 what can I do okay
what about 13 well okay what about four
at some point your body oh but what
about that what does that mean I cannot
train hard to wear I cannot get 15 the
next day no of course I can do that so
at the time physiological breakdown you
cannot go anymore at that time that guy
had my arm there I couldn't move and I
had a tap and that's the truth well if
you can't admit that that that's a hard
pill to swallow that's that's a real
difficult thing to admit you know ego
the the ability to let's say the the
inability to admit I'm not as strong as
I thought I was that that's a scary
thing for a lot of people a lot of it I
think nowadays where everything's
YouTube Facebook me me me right I mean
to actually look at me right and I don't
my own style admit I'm doing something
wrong I'm making a mistake or I'm not as
strong as I thought I was that's a fear
a lot of people have and said I believe
it's an ugly truth to face but if you
can't face that I mean would that be
almost like almost like extreme
ownership of yourself for sure if you
can actually do that I mean I think that
would be overall good investment you can
give yourself so what actually scares
you that's what it is that's so now
here's where the dichotomy autumn's it
because check it out
you want to have that attitude but at
the same time you know I know fighters
and you see fighters that have this
overwhelming confidence and they might
not even be as skilled as their
confidence belies but the confidence
actually works right like they have so
much belief in themselves that they can
can can project that on their opponent
and they sometimes beat their opponent
before they've even step
to the cage hmm yeah there's that
there's a balance right I mean uh on
paper
Conor McGregor vs. Jose Aldo on paper
who should have won that fight
Oh Aldo had more of a history more of a
history I mean more more actual bouts
more victories I mean he was just I
don't know if that I think I would
describe that more spirit and I'm not
just say you have to believe in the
spirit I mean the attitude the the self
yeah is self belief and it's a weird
thing I do know people around that that
outward facade of power that when they
do lose they're gone mm-hmm so I think
it still does apply if you can accept
the ugly truth and the ugly truth could
be I just made a mistake
I want left which I don't right has
happened has happened before I even saw
one cro cop fought Fedor that was a kick
Cro Cop throw through and as a fighter I
know Fedor didn't see it but he put his
head down and threw over and right at
the same time and I could be wrong but
as a fighter his head went down the same
time the leg went up and the leg missed
him by two inches
mmm if Fedor didn't throw that punch
booby kale in my opinion he wouldn't
have got it so what happened was the
kick missed and I believe crow hop fell
down or if we don't talk him down so it
was just well-timed
of course the harder you train the
better your timing is good lucky we get
yes so so sometimes the the truth is
that you should I left and went right
but when you do make a mistake or
something bad happens to you okay how
are you gonna come back from that and I
don't try to sound like the kindergarten
school teacher like on you never know it
just it's only matters you can never
make mistakes and just come back
stronger than ever not trying to sound
like that
but but how do you come back from a
mistake you know not be mr. positive
Aung San well you've done that multiple
times you know obviously the first World
Championship in Brazil in Brazil in 2003
you came back from being how many
matches did you have your first day - I
lost my second match
who'd you lose it to chachi barrel Jones
yeah my nemesis and he beat you on
joints were tied and then he won he won
eight to four or he went by my new he
like ran up the score cuz you gotta take
some risks at the end was tied for two
4112 two for something yeah it was yeah
and there's a turning point in the match
this is actually relevant to to what you
learn and how you you handle things and
make them into a positive there's a move
call to sit through or also know there's
a peek out where you have the bonus legs
and you have to throw yourself under
them and get around to the back and I've
done that move pretty well and I learned
at age fourteen in Restless a wrestling
move how you do not ever look to the
head when I go under I circle around to
your back and I look to your feet no
matter what happens do not look the
other way and others age 14 and with
John G I'm doing the move to him I'm
walking around and I took the wrong way
and that moment of weakness I look back
and John she just was on top and that
was the turning point in the match so
when you looked you'd say you got like
curious and you looked at his head what
it's because it seems like the easier
way to go if fields it feels like if I
go that way I cannot talk it just feels
ugly but it never happens it never
happens I'm going I just kept walking
around and I'm not I don't know what
happened but the next day lo and behold
I faced a very good opponent my
Socceroos page upon from Brazil very
tough guy and he's taller longer and
heavier than John G and at that moment I
believe he was higher rank than Jean
Jean Jean she was already ranked there's
a world champion there well he was
definitely higher ranked in that weight
class yes he was him he was way bigger
would he get 265 something like that
this is a huge guy yeah he freaking
monster he looks like um my goodness
doing a second mutant yeah paid upon was
just like I believe his system
it's the Moose from rocking bull and oh
yeah it's some cartoon character he
looks like a big cartoon and I did this
move to him and I had to walk more than
360 but I did not look back to head and
then I got to him and that was
to any point of that match and I wanna
so if it wasn't for that mistake
literally I don't know if I would have
even you know I'm not saying no but I
made it out of even one the absolute
division so that mistake actually
probably is the reason I won the next
day actually and also I didn't have you
in loop to lose I wasn't the North
American qualifier trying to come out
and I mean I was I was not supposed to
win so I had nothing to lose and that
was a good thing for me to have that day
were you ever able to capture the
attitude of nothing to lose in a
situation like 2011 when you won again
we do you think you captured that did
you have nothing to lose cuz here was
the old man coming in to fight against
the young kids there's no way this guy's
gonna win was that enough to kind of get
your mindset right I think I did I
didn't realize it until afterwards
though because because I'm Spain I would
do Spain with you yeah I'm also bad luck
bad luck it seems like when I'm gonna
Abu Dhabi World Championships with you
you have not won when I'm not with you
you win so bad luck but when we were to
Spain it seemed like there was hype
right there was like yeah you were Dean
Lister you were the I like him back from
bicep surgery yeah so is like hey you
had a bicep surgery but you're back yeah
it was like a lot of expectations around
you 2005 I was the super fight champion
versus the very respected Jean Jacques
Machado and 2007 my bicep snapped I
can't face Roger AC so I was potentially
gonna be the next defending Super Fight
or champ but I doubt because injury so
2009 I come back as the previous guy who
couldn't couldn't couldn't compete face
Rogers still the man yeah that's what it
was so there was a lot of pressure I
remember it felt that way it felt that
way like when we were in Barcelona right
when we were in Barcelona you know you
were like gee mister and and everyone
there was a lot of pressure like hey
it's Dean Lister he's back he's gonna
he's gonna crush everyone and I mean you
did fine but he lost a frickin crappy
match bye-bye refs decision or something
it was it was a very close match a close
match too close to quitting on it
yeah yes but but anyways there was but
then you somehow you were able to go to
England and get the mindset of so now
it's two years later you hadn't you
didn't do good in the previous age maybe
that's one of all it took was you you
didn't do good in the previous one so
now you show up there's no expectations
again oh it's Dean he's he's too old now
he didn't even do good last time don't
worry about Dean and you're over there
gonna cool don't worry about me I'll be
just be over there getting after it just
gonna let loose and it worked
yeah you know you were injured two ribs
right well that was I didn't want to
know about that it was my second match
against see this is another thing I
notice about you like I talked to you
and he I could tell I was actually happy
you had injured ribs because you were
like I got injured ribs it's another one
of those things where I could tell it
was getting your mind into the mode of
you have nothing to lose like I have an
injured ribs and you kind of like I
haven't you ribs but I'm just gonna go
you said I'm not gonna do the absolute
but I'm just gonna do I'm gonna finish
my weight class you know and I was kind
of thinking about self okay he's in that
zone of he has nothing to lose which is
the perfect zone for you to be in well I
told myself when I'm not I'm not the big
praying type but I was like hey I'm
gonna pray and I said God you know if if
you can help me just get this moment and
if I could win my division I promise I
won't do the absolute division but if I
don't win I'm gonna go the application
I'm gonna hurt myself really bad just so
you know that if you want to hurt myself
that's the that's probably one of the
most awkward prayers that God has ever
heard
yeah a probably puzzling story well
you've got friend oh well then I won and
you're supposed to say hey if I can win
I'll dedicate the rest of my life to
helping underprivileged children not if
I win I won't do the absolute if you
don't want me to hurt myself but I think
it worked a when people procrastinate
for for the pain or for them not not the
pain but the but the nerves that they're
about to have is there any way to
overcome like you gotta face the help to
face those nerves there
way to face the nerves earlier I have a
new have you thought of this word the
procrastination of procrastination like
I've actually caught myself even listen
to your words like hey get up right now
and I'm like yeah for later always
thinking I just procrastinate did I just
did exactly what I shouldn't do
so if you actually can catch yourself
realizing when you're procrastinating
that's a big thing because sometimes it
just flies right by you
yeah we're in human beings are really
good at at camouflaging or ignoring or
covering up for procrastination by not
even acknowledging that it's there so
was the question just how to prepare for
the decision or not if this
procrastination I guess my point is that
procrastinating the event coming does
not help you avoid getting nervous well
it's it's something I mentioned earlier
about the truth your true self has one
as one of you two to compete the day of
your competition you might be thinking
what was I damn thinking this is enough
this is uncomfortable these all these
emotions what am I thinking your
self-doubt and the more you compete
they'll get better and better better
even if you don't win your first
tournament even if you lose your first
match you will become better over time
as long as you don't give up but and I
guess the point is that if you if you
get in the habit of procrastinating what
you're supposed to be doing you're gonna
be more nervous you're gonna have more
yeah so anxiety so going into your
situation your original self needs to
actually commit and set a date and sound
doing that day that's it and actually
make sure it's not a date where you have
an excuse like oh it's my my in-laws
wedding anniversary whatever it is you
have no Dantley excuse to get out of it
just find a day we can commit and do it
and then start training and if you feel
that you're procrastinating you actually
I now have a date and that's a lot
harder to procrastinate now they have a
date yeah it's possible it's harder you
know what speaking of looking to the
future so Sarge Sarge used to say when
he was getting ready like two for
wrestling he would he I would say woohoo
you know
we talking about visualization and I'd
say who would you visualize that you're
going against and he would always say I
visualize a blank face and I would just
kill this blank face because and then
like when he actually knows who's gonna
wrestle you know cos you know he's gonna
wrestle such in such a school and I'm
supposed to have this guy but he said I
wouldn't picture that guy's face that
way if it changed yeah I wouldn't be
like caught off guard so you know if
he's wrestling at 1:43 or whatever and
there's someone else you know so he
knows that guy from this school is 143
they knew he knows the guys he knows
what he looks like but he doesn't
picture that guy and pictures a wrestler
with a blank face just a white blank
face and then and then as like the day
arrives and he sees that that guy's made
weight and he's not injured and that's
who he's gonna wrestle then he puts my
face on there and goes out and murders
him he probably says by a sign at least
did he tell you like this looking I can
imagine him talking like that too yeah
well a man those are those are some good
things to talk about I think I think
really the biggest takeaway is like you
are gonna get nervous for competition
you're gonna get nervous for job
interview you're gonna get nervous to
step up and lead for the first time
you're gonna get nervous when you have
your first kid there's all kinds of
situations that you're gonna get nervous
about frame it you know frame it in your
brain understand it understand that it's
not a bad thing
you know like Mike Tyson hey it's okay
I'm gonna be nervous yeah you should be
nervous because it's a big deal and if
you're not afraid of it if you take it
you contain it don't let it run you but
you use that fear you use that anxiety
use those nerves to make you train
harder
maybe that's the part about
procrastination if you procrastinate if
you keep saying well I won't be nervous
right yeah like if you procrastinate
feeling those if you procrastinate
facing those you can get used to like
here we are we're ready yeah you know
you know even when we're training for a
fight and it's like we start training in
the beginning of the camp you know it
doesn't really matter what time of day
you train your training a few times day
but then the closer you get to camp the
more you want the to train around the
time you're actually
in a fight yeah you don't want to
procrastinate either because now you
start thinking okay it's real easy to
say off I'm fighting in six weeks I'm
feeling a little bit nervous I think
this is what I was talking about the
progressive nation thing I'm feeling a
bit a little bit nervous I'm just gonna
bury those thoughts right now yeah you
know what I mean you procrastinate
facing the nerves so I guess what I'm
saying is don't procrastinate face and
there's like exit be like oh yeah I
think about it yeah and think about what
you're gonna do with those nerves don't
procrastinate being nervous because the
nerves will grow and then you won't know
how to handle it what do you think about
Musashi
saying he would envision every possible
wave death falling off a cliff being
incinerated by a fire I'm just going off
from this giant list about now he's
ready for the worst of the worst and
nothing can really scare him yeah that's
that's you know going on the battlefield
already dead is a very positive thing
and you know we had this guy the
Frenchman Doug Letourneau on the podcast
and he was in SOG in Vietnam and they
were doing just the most insane missions
you can possibly imagine and it's not on
the podcast I talked about on the
podcast but because we conversed after
he left or after we stopped recording
but for every operation that he went on
before he went he made his bed he
squared away his footlocker
he put everything in its right place he
removed anything that was you know
questionable or unset so that his
footlocker could be sent home because
every op that he went on he thought he
could die and he wanted to be ready for
it and so if you have that attitude
going in yes I think that's a that's a
great attitude to have I think the worst
attitude you can go into these
situations is is I'm afraid it's gonna
happen I'm not ready for yeah right I'm
not ready to make that sacrifice I'm not
if you face the fact that this is
another procrastination if you look at
if you if you're six weeks away from a
fight or you're six weeks away from a
job interview and you have a quick
thought that I'm gonna get knocked out
or I'm gonna say the wrong thing and not
get the job and instead of saying okay
well what does that mean because if you
if you rationalize and say hey I'm gonna
learn something or I'm gonna learn
something about the job that I didn't
get or I'm gonna have more opportunity
to prepare if you say okay well this is
the worst-case scenario I get
now worst-case scenario I don't get the
job interview cool let's deal with it
right now don't procrastinate look at
what it actually how does that affect
your life because guess what there's
other jobs out there there's other
fights you can do you're gonna get
knocked out at some point let's figure
out what's your mistake you made so if
you look at the thing you don't
procrastinate the nerves you face the
nerves and again the dichotomies I'm not
talking about sitting around and being
nervous for freaking six weeks and
having your adrenaline pumping all the
time yeah I got that so there's there's
there's these things you have to do you
have to anticipate the fact that you're
gonna be nervous and then learn how to
deal with these these thoughts by just
thinking through them and if you think
through them I think that's think that's
the solution you think through what's
the worst-case scenario worst-case
scenario is you get tapped out
junko yeah you want to hear a training
method to even help you more for jujitsu
for this kind of type of thing
absolutely I always have done this and
you are one of the few that never stride
away from this I always start in a bad
position
I always starting almost the worst
position when we start with more yeah
you're aware of this start with you and
like not you specific start with an arm
lock on me mm-hmm and I'm gonna start
from there
because if that's the worst the worst
everyday I'm starting there
first of all I'm meeting a harder
workout than you I'm cheating I'm
selfish actually now my friend may not
see it that way because it's easy day
for him yeah you know he's not risking
his arm but I am actually getting
stronger my my bones my arms are getting
super strong because of the resistance I
get you know and that I think that's one
reason why I can and I'm not saying I
can rest in an arm lock but I think I
can kind of hang out there for a while
you know I think one day I did five arm
locks and you in wrote meaning exactly
what you're saying I started in the arm
lock I started in the arm lock and you
got out of all of them that to me was
ridiculous my unlocks not great but it's
not sad good it is not bad and I
unlocked plenty of people and you were
letting me start in the arm lock I'm
talking in the arm lock like my legs are
I have your arm you should be tapping in
in
than one second that's where I started
so with the arm extended you mean yeah
totally extended do you not remember
this yeah I remember yeah and I was on a
Attica day though I was on him I don't
know I had a real good day well yeah and
actually you what you were doing was you
were showing me something because you
did this escape and I couldn't stop you
and then you said here's what I'm doing
No and it was like the whole thing of
your shoulder going into the thing and
then you showed me the John Jay escape
and I was like god that's the kind of
thing that freaks me out about you
because how did you know that how do you
know that I think it's because you have
a depth of knowledge that's not normal I
don't know I don't know like the fact
it's counterintuitive the way you
escaped that armlock is counterintuitive
no one would think that pushing more
into it would be more beneficial right
yeah yeah but somehow it is well it's
like it's like an you ever get
frustrated untie a knot
you know the knots just they got a cut
on I get frustrated you know I should
just relaxed pushed into the you know
try to pull it apart and knots now it's
done so sometimes if I pull away from a
submission how about I got it ease into
a little bit so I'm in push and I eased
in okay my shoulder went out that's true
but yeah that was a good day for me I
was just on that day I remember that day
was on this this mad are normally out we
train on yeah but if I start and also as
Jean Jacques Machado
he has great great back attacks he has a
great joke we have my training started
with my opponents on my back
half my training started there to where
I can kind of relax in that situation
and if I can start when someone's
mounted on top of me and learn how to
escape that I can use that as my rock
bottom reset point and I can always
reset that point and then that helps you
mentally to relax because if your fear
is I'm getting smashed from the bottom
and I can't breathe start there and
start there and learn how relax and
learn how to escape it it's not it's not
what you want to happen it's what you
want to avoid happening so because of
that start in that situation
put yourself in bad positions box has a
problem getting on the corner start in
the corner in boxing every round you
start in the corner it's gonna suck
mMmmm as soon yeah but you can't say we
had that fighter in Puerto Rican kid oh
yeah a city boxing yeah he he he was
well-rounded but his problem I recall
was being in the corner stuck he was a
small guy but if he wasn't the corner
he'd like you up but if you but learning
how to fight out of the corner
eventually you couldn't hold in the
corner I mean there's things like that
you know
so it's uncomfortable as that is you
have to confront it as soon as you can
and that will also help you from
procrastinating because you are not
procrastinating by in front of your fear
directly as a training method check
shake that's a good place to close man
awesome Dean if you want to talk to if
you want to hit up Dean Lester on social
media he's on instagram at Dean Lister
BJJ right yes and anyone has any kind of
questions you wanted me to go over this
kind of thing Samia little message at
USC BJJ Istanbul mouse mouse yo basil mi
mano home pregunta MA Suzette au SE você
fala uma coisa
and madam textual massage Brigade or
brazos I see the same thing yeah I know
I heard you say pregunta but better yeah
yeah that's Spanish bro yeah I know
there's their close-up and if you want
to hear from me um um at Chaco willing
doc I'm at I just add taco willing yeah
I have another podcast called Jocko
podcast Jocko podcast calm and our Jim
here where Dean and I are at is victory
Jim's calm we're in San Diego California
if you come out to San Diego come by get
some training in hang out and if you
need jujitsu gear go to origin Maine
calm
we got keys that are american-made we
got supplements for life so you can
check that out too
anyways have a good one and go roll
we'll catch you later
[Music]